All right, folks, welcome back.
This is our 27th episode of the continuing series
of the free 2022 ICT Mentorship on YouTube.
All right, so Mastec Daily Chart for June 2022.
And here we have Friday's trading here, OK?
Friday, Thursday, Wednesday, Tuesday, Monday.
So we had a nice little decline down in this week.
And then Friday, we have somewhat of a retracement.
If you've been following my community posts on the YouTube
channel, I mentioned this morning that the 12,553 level
is too clean.
And you can kind of see it in here.
Look at the high on this candle.
It's 12,547.
And then here, this high is 12,553.
So I'm using this as the higher one.
But these are relative equal highs.
That's what I'm looking at.
So I'm thinking that it could draw there.
Now, I was given the opportunity to do so today
based on what I showed in the short little vignettes
I posted on my video section.
I was out and about today.
So obviously, I was sharing what I could on my phone.
I don't generally trade on the phone.
I can manage a position.
But I'm not generally trying to enter trades and such.
But I made a mistake today.
And I was trying to exit, as I'll
talk about in a moment when we get into lower time frames.
But I was showing segments of me recording
where the market was, what it was doing
when I was entering the whole business.
And you'll actually see the execution errors
in all that business here tonight.
But the relative equal highs, that was the draw on liquidity.
Now, the draw on liquidity does not
need to be traded to have a profitable framework or setup.
So what do I mean by that?
Well, if we're below this objective,
and I'm thinking, and you're thinking the same thing,
if you think that the market is going to draw up
to that level, whether it be today or into next week,
you look for a setup that will allow you
some kind of participation in this expansion towards that.
It doesn't need to get there, as you'll soon see.
We're going to drop down into the hourly chart.
So here's the hourly chart.
You can see relative equal highs up in here.
Look at the high on that candle there.
That's the 12,553 and a quarter level.
So that's what I'm framing it on.
And we traded down, started to run higher.
We had a shift in market structure here.
And then just notice how we have had this low, this low swept.
We came down below it, came back above.
These were all to the equal lows.
And then we came back down, tried one more time
to go lower, and then rejected it.
Notice that?
So as the market's starting to trade higher,
where is it likely to go?
Well, we've already taken out a large pool of liquidity
below these relative equal lows.
This is sell side.
Now we're back above these relative equal lows.
So where's buy side?
Clear and obviously right here.
Not really obvious in terms of any imbalance in here,
because we already rebalanced this area there.
So there's nothing really all that exciting
except for that small little section there.
So if it's going to go up to this area here,
my thought process is that it's likely to just punch through
and take the buy stops resting above here.
So that's the draw on liquidity.
Just think of it like a big magnet,
drawing price up towards it.
So we're going to drop down into a 15-minute time frame.
So here's a 15-minute time frame.
And here's Friday the 13th.
You scared?
I ain't scared.
So we have the market trade here, lower, low, low.
So this right here may trip you up.
But this right here was the 930 in the morning manipulation,
where it takes out this overnight London low,
creates the manipulation idea, then rallies.
I was not available during this time,
so I didn't take any trades.
As you'll see, there's no trades in this area.
And then the retracement in here in the afternoon,
that's what I was looking for.
So I wanted to see that type of idea.
So I'm going to add the annotations to the chart now.
All right, so here's the 5-minute chart.
Here's the overnight London lows.
930, we run through it, taking out the sell side here.
And then it starts to rally.
All this rallying up here, I was not able to participate in.
Market trades lower, down into the range between this low
and this high.
What is it trading to?
Discount.
So I'm going to go into this area a little bit tighter.
So we can see here's our consolidation.
It drops down, creates the low of the day, power 3.
So it's accumulating long positions,
manipulating early longs out of the market,
taking out the stops overnight, then rallying.
And then I'm looking for the continuation
up to take out the relative equal highs here,
because I think I'm still going to see continuation
in the afternoon.
So I want to buy this discount market,
and I'm going to be buying inside of this curve I got,
because it's at or below equilibrium between this low
and that high.
All right, so I've added the annotations here.
And I've got to adjust this, because my obsessive-compulsive
disorder is flaring.
It's like a spider sense, folks.
Can't help it.
All right, so we have the New York session open at 9.30
in the morning, New York local time.
Creates the low of the day, rallies.
Creates the high here.
At what time?
What time is this candle here?
It's 12, 10.
That's that lunch time.
I told you it creates usually a retracement of some sort,
or consolidation.
Then it retraces lower.
And then here is 1.30, right about there.
So at 1.30, the algorithm will start seeking liquidity.
If it's going to continue higher,
what's it likely to do?
Seek sell-side.
So where sell-side?
Well, we have relative equal lows here.
But is that a discount from here to here?
Mm-mm, no.
So this dashed line here that's in purple,
I have that noted as equilibrium.
That's essentially the same thing
as taking the fib from here to here, and that's 50%.
OK, so now we have equilibrium there.
The market drops down into equilibrium,
and then below it into the fair value gap here.
This candle's high.
This candle's low.
That's your imbalance.
Fair value gap is here.
So the market drops down into it here at 2 o'clock
in the afternoon, 2.05, 2.15, 2.20, 2.25,
and then displacement.
We'll see this fair value gap on the lower time frames
I'm going to go through and let you see it.
But this displacement on the outside
is a shift in market structure.
In a day that's likely to be bullish,
this countertrend to a higher time frame,
we're working with the logic that it's probably
going to be a retracement, because we've been down
for a long time now, and most people are probably
going to want to get out over the weekend.
So the algorithm's going to start squeezing on them
to get their positions squared before the close of the Friday.
So in this area here, we're going to drop down
into a four-minute chart.
No fair value gap shown here, except for this small little
area there.
Now, by itself, that's possible.
You get a small little return into it there.
I'm not looking at that.
Go down into a three-minute chart.
There's a gap there.
Again, you can see that candle right there.
That would be fine if that's what you were looking for.
And then a two-minute chart.
There is, I've got to set my chart back.
It's got to be the way I want it, folks.
All right, so we have down-closed candles in here,
order block, fair value gap.
This candle's low.
This candle's high.
There's our imbalance and order block.
It trades down, drops into that.
And I'm going to show you the executions here.
So as it's dropping down in here,
you can see I have, let me hover to the top of this thing,
about 36 contracts.
And the assumption is we're using a discount broker,
something like AMP Futures.
I'm not repping AMP Futures, by the way.
But they have really low margins.
So that would be allowed for something
with the equity that was used in this example today.
These are paper trades.
Is that what you guys know for compliance reasons
and full disclosure?
I'm illustrating execution and theory.
I'm also showing you what I was doing when I was on Twitter,
when I did use MT4, which I don't do anymore.
I haven't used MT4 in years.
I don't need to have a fake MT4 server to be able to do this.
This is what I was doing, and I was trading it
and building it up and building it up and building it up.
So in a matter of a week or so, I've taken a $100,000 account,
took it to over $300,000.
And you'll see that here in a second.
But as it was dropping down, dropping down, all this candle
here, I was buying at the beginning of the fair value
gap and about the middle of it.
And I was trying to get into the lower portions of it,
but it didn't quite get down there.
So the fair value gap in this shaded area,
that's what's being shown here.
Take that off for clarity's sake.
And we drop in here.
I mentioned in the small little vignette, again,
I've done three videos today that were basically silent.
I put a little bit of a music thing on it just to,
I don't know, I was testing it out.
I was really disappointed it didn't
play the entire time the video was playing, but whatever.
The idea was I was showing you that when
we went into the order block, it was going to rally up.
And it rallied up, and then I took off 10.
Small little vignette shows me closing 10 contracts there.
And I was looking for it to maybe stage a run up
into that 12, 553 level that I mentioned on my community
posts.
But obviously, we were running out of time today.
And I messed up on the close of the 20 contracts
because I wanted to take off 20 above here.
And I tried to put it in as a limit order,
but it ended up closing as market.
So what I should have done was, and I said this
to my private group too, I'm working with Trading View,
but I'm used to using actual live platforms.
So the things that I can do in other places
I can't necessarily do here, and because I'm doing it
on my phone and I was out doing other things in real life,
and this is the reason why you don't want
to be trading off of your phone.
But anyway, I ended up closing the 20 here.
So I didn't get it above that 12, 430 level
I was trying to aim for.
So I missed it there.
And then I closed more here and here.
And then finally, late in the day, I had one left,
and I just took it off here.
So that's the business there.
And I want you to look at how the market created
this counter trend idea, but still using my fair value
gap principle and concept.
Liquidity was above here.
The day was bullish.
The algorithm kept pricing higher and higher and higher.
And the logic was delivered here.
So look at where the errors are for entries.
And this was a failure on my part.
I didn't get the price I actually wanted.
None of these closures were actually
above the 12, 430 level.
That was, I think, the closest one.
Yeah, that was the closest one there.
And I had one left over here, and that
was the final bit of business.
I was leaving it just in case some freaky occurrence where
it would take us up in some parabolic run into 12, 5, 5,
3, but this wasn't in the cards today.
We're going to steam.
You can frame what I'm teaching inside of a counter trend
model if that's what you are by nature a contrarian.
If you want to be trading with the highest probability
and in sync with the early session move,
then trade exactly how I've outlined the principles
around that 830 to 930 window.
I'm trying to do my best to give you a little bit of freedom
to try to make it your own and inspire you also
that these fair value gaps are useful if you
know what the bias is.
And I know some of you are still posting in the comments section.
I'm still struggling with bias.
It's only because you haven't worked at it long enough.
You're not going to watch a dozen of my videos
and come away.
Now, I know exactly how to do bias.
You have to go into the charts and study each day back testing.
What is back testing?
Going back and looking at moves like this.
Marking them up on your chart.
Now, you can do it either using the replay button,
watching them paint partially, or you
can go back in hindsight and mark up your chart like this.
This is all back testing.
All this is is me showing you what I actually did.
Now, I was going to be facetious and talk
about this, for those that didn't really
see the videos that I posted today,
where I actually did the pushing of the button here.
The idea of me seeing it before it happens,
that's proof of concept and it's proof of understanding.
So I'm the author of this algorithm,
so I can operate in it very efficiently.
You, as a student of mine, you have
to understand my language first.
And then you go into the charts and you study with that language
and you'll be able to see repeating phenomena.
And because you're able to do this in your own leisure,
you collect these examples of hindsight movement
with all of your annotations and your points of interest
that you studied and see in your observations.
Anywhere in a chart where it's empty space,
you want to utilize that and have any kind of observation
or encouragement to yourself.
And you want to tell yourself in those commentaries
that you saw this coming.
And what this does is it tricks your brain.
It's self-talk.
It's one of the things that I actually
used to overcome agoraphobia, which
was the fear of being around other people
because I had extreme anxiety that started, obviously,
from trading because I built up this large image of myself.
And in 2001, all that stuff happened.
And I was afraid of a lot of things.
And I had serious anxiety attacks, panic attacks
that would come on out of nowhere.
The coping skills that I learned to deal
with generalized anxiety, I found
that were very useful in teaching my students.
And it was simply by taking positive self-talk,
placing that into your back testing,
where you're note taking.
By all face value of it, you're lying to yourself
in these posts in your back testing.
So in your study journal, only you are seeing it.
But you're tricking your brain and your subconscious
because you're writing it out in your own words.
You're studying it.
You're looking at it.
Your subconscious is retaining the image.
But it's also retaining what you're saying in it.
So when you come back to it at the end of the week
previous week's back testing log journals, you read them.
And when you read them to yourself,
you're reading your own words saying, I saw this setting up
where this was likely to drop down here.
And I was expecting this turn here
because of the fair value gap.
I wanted to see this displacement.
And it occurred just like I was expecting.
And it comes back down in and allows me an opportunity
to go long.
Then I expected the market to move aggressively away
from this area and start working towards these short-term highs.
And I wanted to take something off above halfway, high to low.
I want to take a premium profit scaling.
And that's what that is there.
So you're pouring yourself into the chart
with your annotations for back testing.
And you're doing it in such a way
where you're tricking your subconscious like you
expected this to happen.
And over time, when you do that, you're
recording this subconsciously.
You don't realize you're doing it.
But by doing these things over and over and over again,
it activates your reticular activating system.
It's the same thing happens when you buy a car.
You go out the next day.
And all of a sudden, it seems like everybody else
bought the same car.
The only difference is you've been more sensitive to that
because it's more meaningful to you.
So these charts will take on that same characteristic
when you make them more meaningful to you.
How do you do that?
You place your personality and your interest in the chart.
So everything here, I'm giving you a narrative here.
You would do the same thing, just typing it out
and putting in there, and then screen capturing it
and storing it in your journal or printing it out
and putting in your journal.
Those things, over time, will start building
on your subconscious as pseudo memories.
So critics that hear me say this are going to be like,
oh, this fraud's telling you to lie to yourself.
I'm being honest.
You are lying in the chart when you do your annotations
for study purposes.
You're tricking your brain like you had experience
seeing this happen.
But because, over time, you're doing that,
your subconscious will retain that.
And when you start seeing it live, it will remember, hey,
I remember that because I did that before,
when you technically really didn't.
But then now you have pseudo experience.
It sounds strange, like it couldn't possibly work like this,
but it does.
Our brains are extremely intricate.
They're very powerful,
but they can be short-circuited a little bit
and used in an advantageous way of studying.
And this is one way I teach my students in mentorship.
And this is what I'm trying to suggest
that you do for your back testing.
All you have to do is look at old moves,
study them, annotate your chart.
As rich as you want that chart to be,
that's what you're doing.
You're trying to make it as meaningful to you
as you possibly can.
And over time, you'll create a measure of pseudo experience
that will build upon over time, how much time?
I don't know.
Although you're gonna develop at your own pace
and you're gonna arrive at full understanding right on time.
So it might be a couple of weeks for some of you,
may take a year for others,
may take a little bit longer than that.
It depends on what you pour yourself into by doing it.
And I'll leave that part up for you
to decide how much effort you're gonna put into it.
But I wanted to share something today
and kind of like answer those individuals
that like to say that MT4 rented servers were used and stuff.
And I don't need that folks.
I mean, it's not necessary.
So let's go over here.
Go over here.
And you can see there's 100,000
and there's some red in there folks, see that?
Two back to back losing trades.
Okay, and that was the business.
Okay, that was since the sixth of this month.
100,000 account to 354,000.
Paper trading, obviously,
but that's what I was doing on Twitter all those years.
I was showing and showing and showing.
And this proves concept.
It proves that these things work.
I'm looking at live data when I'm doing this.
This is actually no delay.
You can see there's no D up here.
There's no little dot showing it.
It's as real as real can be, okay?
If I can't see these things happening before it happens,
it will fail.
But if I can see them live forming
and I have an understanding
what the algorithm is gonna do,
then I should be able to operate like this.
And I saw a comment today
on one of the video vignettes I did.
And can we get past the drama
and the proving who made money?
I'm not sure what the poster intended with that
because I thought that was what you wanted to see
when you came here.
Why would you come to my channel
or anyone else's channel
that has anything to do with technical analysis or trading
if they can't prove they can do what they say they can do?
All I'm doing is sharing my experience
and the prowess I have.
If I can't do this, I'll fall on my face.
I can do it.
And I wanna be encouragement to those
that are genuinely concerned
because they see stupid stuff posted on the internet.
Folks, listen, I don't know how much of this you need to see
before you finally get over it,
but I don't mind doing it, okay?
I don't mind doing it.
I enjoy doing this.
I enjoy sharing it.
And I know it's an encouragement to people
that had a little bit of doubt,
say, hey, look, did you really use an MT4 rented server
on Twitter?
Because we don't really see it.
We just hear other people talking about it.
Well, here's again, more proof that,
listen, this is just a matter of like a week or so.
In five and a half weeks or six weeks,
I could easily do what I'm doing here
and it compounds over and over and over again, okay?
Just because I'm doing it with a demo account
doesn't mean that you're gonna be able to go out there
and do it too with a live account.
The only thing I'm showing you here
is I understand what I'm doing.
So I think that's gonna be it for tonight
and I will touch base with you Lord willing
next Tuesday for another lecture.
And it'll probably be a little bit longer video then, okay?
Until then, enjoy your weekend, be safe.